[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
of course
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
just as real as real can be
is
[Music]
delicious last course if there's a
single meal to help us realize
[Music]
what's going on guys
we're gonna we're gonna try man we're
gonna try this
i haven't played it now i did
play a couple of the old bosses just to
get a little bit
hype back into the matter
but as far as like
playing the game
like anything of the new content
so you know
we're gonna see man we're gonna see i i
think
i think i got this i don't know i was
struggling yesterday on some of the
older bosses it wasn't even one of the
harder bosses
so i'm curious if i'll be able to do
this i don't know
let me make sure everything sounds good
turn this down i always like my voice
being a little bit louder than the
actual game
so everything should be good you guys
know how things are man
we think things are good
and it's not
it's horrible
[Music]
it's been legit years since i played
this
like legit
years
[Music]
i need to be a bit louder
all right hold up
the mic is almost maxed out
see this is what's up and this is
all right how is that does that sound
better
this is the thing i'd be talking about
when people
are like
aj you well addict my my name's aj but
they like addicts we can't hear you
addicts you
you're too loud
like i
now bro you loud
okay i'm loud okay okay let's try it
again take two
all right what about now do i sound fine
now am i too loud
am i loud for everyone
okay i think that's the wrong thing
am i too loud
i need that feedback guys i need that
feedback
all right so i'm assuming we take this
to go to the new location i'm assuming
we take this
this is all new content too guys keep in
mind this is new content
you know what let me go ahead
and make
add something here a little bit
all right all right
so i to be honest with you guys i'll be
real with you i don't care about the
story of cuphead
i feel like if you care about the story
cuphead
then
you don't know what like you don't know
what this is about man
[Music]
you care about the story cuphead
you lost
bring this down a little bit
[Music]
uh
all right i don't know i'm not messing
with it it's fine
stay on your guard stupid cups fetching
the ingredients will be the test of wits
and wills but remember like any good
bake heart and soul is the secret
ingredient
oh
all right so apparently we're getting
ingredients for food of some sort
i guess
one more thing chops remember to equip
that nifty cook charm in the menu if you
want to battle as miss chalice
[Music]
all right so
play his mechanics in her double jump
dash
all right we'll see we'll see
i wonder what the first mission is
[Music]
oh okay here it is
is this a boss
or is this like a mission
[Music]
i should probably switch this up
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there's something in the back
okay okay
all right all right all right all right
let me switch things up let me switch
things
now
up
[Music]
all right there we go
[Music]
are these attacks coming from
[Music]
oh my god
i'm so rusty
[Music]
wow so you have to fight on three
platforms okay let me go let me return
to the map and switch things up i don't
think the the right thing for me using
is the uh
is the charge one
let's just do the regular pea shooter
spiritual ghostly garage
okay
i don't like how you have to use an
entire
slot just to play as a new character
i think that that's pretty crazy if you
ask me
all right let's do this let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
how far has he come all right so
okay so i'm kind of confused when
he actually gets there all right all
right all right let's do this again
so i gotta go down there to the bottom
for that move
i'm trying to remember how to parry
[Music]
could she not parry
can she not perry
what's going on with the period man
hold up
all right so the geese you have to go to
the bottom i just have to be a little
bit better on how i dodged that
so i keep losing platforms the most the
more damage he takes it looks like
[Music]
all right so what is this about
so we got a little platform now
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we got it looks like one has
like a ball
[Applause]
all right all right we're good we're
good
the geese is ridiculous
oh my god
all right all right i gotta watch the
bottom man i gotta watch the ball
alright so he's already doing this
i'm still confused if
she can
do pairing
i'm assuming i'm just doing it wrong
there's no way that she can't ferry
all right so let's just dodges let's not
try to to cause any damage right now
let's just dodge
[Music]
[Music]
man there's just a lot of going on you
have to be on the move
yeah i'm gonna have to be on the move a
little bit more
[Music]
so here's the geese
[Music]
all right so it looks like they're
motion control down there
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right so it's motion control down
there
and and the
the ads down there can die so i have to
keep that in mind
all right all right we good we good we
good so it's motion control down there i
need to keep that bottom platform a
little bit clearer
there goes me trying to parry again
i she she can't marry like there's no
way
[Music]
this map will get red hot
[Music]
all right all right all right we got
this man we got this
[Music]
oh come on man come on
[Music]
so the cat can't really reach me from up
there
but these ads can so we gotta
oh my god
i gotta remember they come back
[Music]
all right all right all right all right
i'm getting pretty consistent now i know
i can go to the left to right and dodge
the geese
pretty easy
[Music]
[Music]
no we got to get rid of these these
people at the bottom
[Music]
yeah i gotta stay away from that right
side i feel like um
here let me um
let me switch stuff around i don't like
how i have to use her ability like that
like you shouldn't have to use a
a part to use her ability i think that's
that's kind of crazy if you think about
it
all right yeah i like the invisible dash
i feel like that's not really doing much
either
all right let's let's do one for close
one for long range
all right so with this
i just have to hold x to dog
[Music]
now it's not as strong as uh certain the
other moves
[Music]
but
i can switch them when i need to
the only time i really need it is when
i'm oh yeah she she has a she has a
double dog
i got to figure out how to use her dash
his dash again
all right so it's why
[Music]
let's get rid of these things oh my god
all right all right
now go
[Music]
why is definitely not a very
good thing to be using
i'm not gonna lie i missed that double
jump she had
[Music]
i missed that double jump she had
[Music]
oh my god i got to be a little bit
better on timing with that
he's got a sec he's got a third form
[Music]
all right i got to be better with that
[Music]
[Music]
can't go back man
i'm panicking i'm panicking way too much
yeah so he
i i knew i wasn't doing something wrong
[Music]
let's get rid of this little
door thing
[Music]
all right all right all right all right
we got we're going somewhere now though
[Music]
all right let's do this the stupid geese
moves man
oh my god i gotta go to the left
and dodge to the right when he does the
geese move
[Music]
got to go to the left to dog to the
right what's got a par
fine i was used to that double jump now
i got a
result but i'm just
for some reason i'm not feeling the um
[Music]
the the dash anymore
now i do face through stuff
come on let's do as much damage as
possible
[Music]
i wish the dash button was a different
move
[Music]
jeez man like the dash button why is it
that move
hold up i
i see the chat picking up a little bit
i feel like that wasn't really
responsive
can i change the settings man
the dash
i mean uh
ace jumped
x to shoot
left bumper so that doesn't look like
any of the back triggers are used
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
let's make the dash button
i'm pressing it
[Music]
all right so let's try this
[Music]
all right so that feels a lot better
that feels a lot better
[Music]
oh it goes left and right okay is this
yeah this is the new dlc post
[Music]
why isn't that
oh my gosh i remember the the parry now
it's just so inconsistent sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't
[Music]
you gotta kill those things at the
bottom man
if you don't they're gonna be problems
[Music]
[Music]
all right so there's the first one
man okay he throws that beach ball
all right but
i'm getting consistency though
[Music]
this is like my damage thing
[Music]
got to get rid of this dude as fast as
possible
[Music]
i keep getting here
[Music]
okay okay okay you can dash left and
right with that ability
[Music]
oh my god the smoke messes with me
already get that timing
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
all right so i'm getting that part down
pretty well
i gotta stay on that top one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know how i got hit that time
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i messed up that time
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
i think that's gonna go down here soon
[Music]
wow okay okay okay
i gotta come down on on the uh
the parries
it's the geese
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right all right all right
[Music]
[Music]
dodge right into it man
now go
[Music]
all right all right i'm getting a little
frustrated
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
nothing i could do they were everywhere
i don't have that
[Music]
i just see that's why i don't like
pairing in this game because i just feel
like it's so inconsistent
[Music]
i should have dodged that i don't know
why i didn't dodge that
that was ridiculous
okay should have dodged that too i
wasn't paying attention to the goose i
don't know why i didn't
[Music]
seeing that i could do
[Music]
[Music]
i knew i was gonna get hit by that
[Music]
all right all right all right let's do
this let's do this
[Applause]
it looks like oh dawg straight into it
that's my b that was my beat
all right let's
let's go back to the map let's
re-evaluate some of these
all right
we're gonna go with the charge again
because i feel like that's just working
out better for me
okay we're gonna go with this
now i'm feeling pretty confident in this
setup
oh my god i hate that
you're up
[Music]
see the thing is i got to be able to
okay
i'm hitting him pretty hard man
[Music]
i have no clue how that didn't hit me
wow
famous last words
i got you man
[Music]
oh my god
i gotta stay in the front i just got to
i'm gonna just start doing it when i
right before i do damage
[Music]
always be losing damage from dumb stuff
man
i don't know it's the first boss
i can't really
give my opinion on that yet
i mean i'm starting to find ways around
it so
[Music]
wow i don't feel like that should have
hit me
oh my god
[Music]
the goose
[Music]
all right so we're good we're good let's
do this
[Music]
all right this one's got the ball so
let's teleport closer to him
wow it's like he he knew i was gonna do
that man he knew i was gonna do that
[Music]
so you gotta
worry about like mad stuff
[Music]
so
[Music]
how how
that game is special
[Music]
i just got to get a little bit farther
without losing health i need to be more
consistent
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
one second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
yeah i'm starting to get a little
frustrated
i don't know why i didn't even move
all right all right all right
[Music]
okay these these
these flowers are getting annoying man
see that perry put me in harm's way
[Music]
like his go-to
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't even know i guess one came below
me and hit me
i gotta get there with more help
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
if i could just get there without losing
so much help
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
i gotta get there with more health i
just got to there's no way around
[Music]
oh my god that dude popped up right when
i didn't need him to pop up
[Music]
all right there we go all right all
right so i learned i don't have to take
care of anyone that's around me
the one to the right has it this
teleport
one to the left
that's it with teleport
[Music]
all right let's just get free hits
all right third form
[Music]
yeah they tripping
they tripping
they are tripping
wow the dude ate me
[Music]
[Music]
he ate me
a great
i think she's gonna let that man eat me
like that
i'm not feeling that
how they just don't let that man eat me
like that it's pretty graphic too
[Music]
look at this
dog
[Music]
come on
oh i messed up how did i do that
how did i do that
all right so he's got it let's go over
here
let's go over here
over here
[Applause]
i should have should have
should have teleported did something man
[Music]
i don't like these things
yeah it should have been a little bit
more to the right
yeah that was crazy
[Music]
okay okay
the parries are starting to be in it i'm
starting to be an addict to the parries
do the parries when they make sense
don't do them when they don't make sense
oh god oh god
[Music]
all right so we shouldn't have to worry
about that dude down there well that one
we have to worry about
that one i'm pretty sure we have to
worry about too
all right let's get back up here
[Music]
all right so we we're starting to be
consistent
now remember we want to go to the one
that doesn't have the ball
because we can teleport into the one
that does
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
they set me up there
[Music]
wow all right all right all right
[Music]
that one's a little bit longer than it
should i feel like
the damage with that is kind of crazy
oh okay hold up
you don't really gotta worry about stuff
until it's right on you
you gotta learn to like like some of
these
these things go
except for this one
so remember the goose
the goose goes right to the left so we
have to go all the way to the left to
the right
we have to go with them and teleport
into them
like this
[Music]
and we want that thing gone because he
messes up our
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
all right so we're good there
let's do this
[Music]
teleport
all right so we want
to dodge
so they're spawning below us i need to
be a little bit more
more cautious to the stuff below me
during that phase
[Music]
the smoke's not really that bad anymore
i kind of get a good
handle on the smoke
[Music]
that cat ain't doing nothing to me
uh by the time i tried to turn over it
was too late
[Music]
we go uh i was about to just reset
gotta get in there with at least two
health man i'd like to get to the to the
inside of his stomach with a decent
amount of health
that dude spawned right when i fell
hold up hold up
[Music]
oh there's the goose
now remember it takes a couple seconds
for those things to pop up
yeah i knew i was dead
well at least i knew i was gonna take a
little bit of damage
[Music]
all right so we're good there
[Music]
[Applause]
so we want to pay attention
to the throwing
into the things that there's falling
because i think i'm losing the most
damage there
so you just want to look down
and just make sure you're not getting
hit by those things yeah i said i should
have teleported right there probably
would have been fine
yeah i've been doing james i've been to
it one time
[Music]
oh there's the goose
oh god
[Music]
all right there we go there we go
now remember we want to look at the
bottom
[Applause]
oh one got out oh they're getting out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we we want to get to the next
part
[Applause]
[Applause]
how much damage this thing will take
there you go man
taking a bunch of damage what's up bad
[Music]
uh
it's gonna be hard to fight him
i might have to use the uh
the green thing for that part so i can
just focus on dodging stuff might take
longer to actually do it but i think
it's a better thing
that charge thing ain't really doing me
any good to be honest
good day foreign
[Music]
i knew i was gonna take a little bit of
damage
yeah let's reset they got me all messed
up got all the platforms to the right
gone
[Music]
um
[Music]
i noticed that pretty quick
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's dodge these let's not
take some damage just some clouds man we
better than that let's kill this thing
too
[Music]
all right so we're good there
he didn't take no damage it's the
important part we didn't take no damage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did that thing hit me how did it hit
me
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know why i jumped there
[Music]
[Music]
all right trying to do as much damage as
possible guys
remember the biggest obstacle in this
thing is these clouds
everything else is manageable
[Music]
even these goose are pretty manageable
you just gotta
know how to fight
them there we go see we're getting there
pretty pretty consistently every time
now
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
how much damage does this thing take
couldn't risk it
three fours man three forms
[Music]
oh there's chicken he throws two so he's
throwing chicken throwing a missile the
platforms disappear and he's going
around himself he's being a moving
target
a lot of moving parts going on there
i hope you don't have a whole lot of
help
would be unfortunate
[Music]
can't risk it and hit there
so i'm getting there quicker every time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god trying to kill them before
they come out
but it's definitely not like
something that you have to worry about
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
after three hours i just gotta get to
that part a little bit more
[Music]
i gotta get to that part a little bit
more
maybe if i switch to a super that does
damage that focuses on damage
i can get through
this part a little bit faster be a
little bit more consistent
[Music]
i don't know guys what you guys think
oh the goose
[Music]
they trying to get me to jump that's
what they're trying to do
[Music]
all right all right
let's see if i could do it without using
the dash a whole lot because i'd like to
change the dash out
but i think that dash is helping me
really good with this
part here
[Music]
i mean come on man
[Music]
thank you i just feel like that's so
long
okay so he throws the chicken bones
oh my god
like
really
[Music]
get that perry
get that pair
[Music]
uh i've been i've been on this i'm
getting to a third form pretty
consistently now it's just learning his
third forms
is being a little bit uh
annoying
his third floor is kind of crazy post up
this forum is annoying
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
three
oh my god
[Music]
how far in this game is this is the
first boss man the first boss
first boss
how you guys like them apples
yeah i would
[Music]
try to get a little bit of a little bit
of damage before the goose
all right so we're good there
all right maybe i just shoot this
because i don't have to worry about
now i feel like it's gonna take forever
if i do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i think we might have
a solution to our problems
[Music]
all right all right so it looks like
they do go away but you have some stuff
to like really
okay okay okay
all right all right
what we want
is we want an extra help
[Music]
[Music]
oh goose oh
all right
yeah i already took some damage
what's going on guys i see you guys
typing in the chat
just give me a second
oh yeah i don't i don't i don't
disappear anymore i gotta keep that in
mind
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right
let's do this guys let's do this
all right so
a little bit of a cheese not i'm pretty
sure he'll he'll move stuff up
right there but that is a pretty good
safe area to be in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we got
more of that okay we're going to keep
going one's fine
two is not fine we cannot lose two in
that area
i prefer not to lose any
but we can't lose two
[Music]
[Music]
so it's the geese all right so all we do
is go to the left just fly back over
not a big deal
no nothing to really worry about there
all right so we got our super
might go away from the uh the
invincibles
why am i doing that
[Music]
that's getting on my nerves
i think that one might hit me i don't
think none of them hit you
[Music]
wow
this ain't really happening
is this really happening
yeah they might want to they might want
to patch that you know
[Music]
just a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
oh so you ha it's one of those things
where you have to okay
okay
you have to do that i got you
[Music]
definitely shouldn't have
risked
i don't know
i feel like i shouldn't have risked
that on that
but you know
that's unfortunate
geese zone
they give you a little bit of
opportunity man just a little bit
i thought i'd kill him i don't know why
all right all right
let me let me pause real quick talk to
the chat
the
i'm part of the uh second boss mooch i'm
off dad you got the rhythm down found
the sweet spot in that part
well now you have a quick way of beating
that second form i'm on the last boss i
had to take a break might finish
tomorrow that's what's up man i just
started
how let's restart we don't do that
i i put the invincibility
just to learn um
just to learn the boss like
[Music]
the goal is to
not use anything the goal is to not use
anything but that invincibility gives me
a little bit more opportunity to learn
the boss in that area
okay i need to get a little bit
no there's nothing after the stomach
part if you look at like when i die it
tells you
it tells you how many phases he has
that's his last phase
these geese they're not really an issue
to be honest with you i pretty much
found all the issues in this part
okay i don't like when they put that
platform that far away
[Music]
okay okay i'm starting to progress
we're not progressing
[Music]
okay i'm progressing pretty hardcore
[Music]
just clear that
let's clear it again
all right so we still got all of our
health so we're doing good so far
this is ridiculous
[Music]
can i even get hit here
[Music]
i don't think you can get hit here
oh i did i finally got hit
i got hit twice
all right it's like a hundred percent
happening but you could definitely
make it work man you could definitely
make it work
[Music]
look at this
look at this
[Music]
bring it
bring it
done
over
i parried a lot
[Music]
i didn't parry any of that game
that's interesting
i thought i parried that
[Music]
you got the promo berries i don't know
crown berries i don't know
[Music]
i don't know what this is
i think that's uh
did it disappear okay
only interested in the boss is to be
honest with you guys
what is this
all
right hey i feel like i should kill
these things before they become an issue
yeah let's kill these things
what are you doing
ow
[Music]
look at this witch
whack ass cards
[Music]
only thing you got really got to worry
about is uh
these little ghost things
and they're not even really an issue
that is an issue but i couldn't dodge it
[Music]
a bonus boss that you have to beat with
no guns
how am i supposed to be a bonus boss
that i have to beat with no guns
that don't even make sense
look at this ow maybe i should have did
that a little bit better
like the boss
[Music]
she's really about these uh
[Music]
oh my god i feel like i'm not doing as
much damage i should be doing
all right now what is this
okay so she falls
it's a refrigerator one of these gonna
be pink oh they they separating the
other stuff
okay okay okay
see uh for the person that didn't see
this if you see those like little lines
that indicates another form so i got
past the first form looks like she has
another form or him i don't know what it
is between that and beating them for
good
and i didn't mean to go back
but it's okay
it's okay man it's okay
we gonna do this
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't like how it's so far away
okay
whatever wizard a brawl is surely
brewing
and begin
warlord
[Laughter]
[Music]
i feel more comfortable using this i
don't know why
i feel like i need to go the other way
whatever way that they are at when she
does that i need to go the other way
they kind of fly towards me if you see
that
so let me try to be at the bottom
like the middle so they always
oh so it's red
okay
i didn't even see that
okay so i can't move until it's done
[Music]
there's a card
might as well use it
let's go throw the thing at me next
that's not too difficult
[Music]
oh now he's rolling
got a modern roly-poly
[Music]
okay all right all right all right
[Music]
i don't think the tracking beam uh it's
helpful but
i don't know
we'll have to see man well i have to see
that second one's the one i want but it
wasn't a good position for me to get
that perry that easy fairy
[Music]
i wanted that perry
looks like they're random
[Music]
all right so it kind of spawns
so you want to go where it centers
really that's what it looks like
[Music]
i was
[Music]
okay okay got a little bit further into
that one a little bit
[Laughter]
come on give me a pink one man
stop being annoying
i don't know why i just did that i'm
gonna restart i don't know why i just
did that
seems like the greyhound bloods
following him more they do
the problem is like they're way weaker
than like the shotgun and stuff
[Music]
isn't it
gotta make sure i get him this time
[Music]
i like to kill them before they even get
out the problem with the
[Music]
the
the shotgun is it's a little bit too
inconsistent
[Music]
now go in
going from where
they originated from
all right all right all right so let me
go back
let me return to the map
let me put my uh dash back on
i feel like that dash will be helpful
right now
the dash is helpful i'm gonna use it
here's a real high class belt
[Music]
i kind of figure i can kill him for some
reason
[Music]
see now that i got my dash
i'm hoping that second form is a little
bit easier
[Music]
[Music]
oh you tricked me
[Music]
all right so you just go in the middle
one
[Music]
[Music]
all right dash towards him
oh
i didn't even notice that when did they
did was that always been there i wonder
if that's always been there
good day
it's on
all right we're really sorry
here they really appreciate that
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right let's do this
gotta find out where they went
destroy them then start back on damage
man
damage is really important you got to
constantly be doing as much damage as
you possibly can
doesn't look like i'm gonna get any
any parries this round
i'm not trying to risk it i'm not trying
to put myself in a situation
[Music]
look at this big thing
oh he switched switch it on
[Music]
all right so i got to worry about the
popsicles but i'm pretty sure i i can
get past that second form now this
tracking thing is really good i could
just focus on dodging
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at this thing
you want to kill them all though you
don't want to get sidetracked
get that parry
[Music]
let's get that parry
[Music]
all right so i like doing this one
because
i can focus on dodging him
and i have to really focus on anything
else
[Music]
so
oh how much should i do though
oh right there right there on the third
form
i think i'll get to his third form here
soon
[Laughter]
come on man
that's [ __ ] how'd he get up so fast
[Music]
i don't understand how he got up so fast
[Music]
i'll take that
i don't know why i try
[Laughter]
all right let's do this guys
let's do this chat
i got you
so we want to do this just get a little
bit of free hits
before he starts doing this stuff on us
then switch to this for the little ice
cube things
[Music]
these are the big ones yes i should have
dodged them
[Music]
all right kind of panic there i
definitely panicked there
i got to do better i can't panic
[Laughter]
[Music]
try to stay in the middle a little bit
to always have damage going to
so
[Music]
all right this should be one over there
i think i got rid of it though i need a
pink car there we go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just at the i can't use
those on that
okay see the problem about the tracking
one when you do that second phase
is it's harder to kill those popsicles
[Laughter]
see they
they set me up man they set me up to
fail that time
[Music]
[Music]
so come on
all right so
let's try things a little bit different
[Music]
oh my god i gotta be better on that
[Music]
all right so they got that diameter man
i got to be better on that
what's up roseanne
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
i don't know why i thought i could just
walk casually not get hit by that
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right so it looks like we're doing
pretty good
might make it through a whole phase
without taking any damage
oh we did all right
[Music]
oh my god see he gets you with both of
them together
that's how he gets you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
a brawl is surely brewing
now go
good day foreign
roxanne is that what you're trying to
get me to pronounce i'm horrible
pronouncing stuff
i feel like that's just not doing no
damage man
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right so we got hit once not too bad
not too good either
[Music]
i feel like i got to stay on the other
side for this boss
[Music]
because it's easier to like sit where
everything's going to be
all right so that's what i got to do i
got to stay on the other side of that
when he does attack me i'm able to know
what
what attack he's gonna do
oh my god
here's a real high-class belt
here
i don't think it's uh
i think i could do it without using her
i found my trier though
i don't know why that hit
see i got a switch
[Laughter]
why sometimes they come up faster
sometimes they don't
like it kind of makes
the timing's not making sense
see like sometimes they come up fast
sometimes they don't
[Music]
why are they is it when i hit them is
that what's going on
when i hit them they do that
what is the
yeah okay so i can't
hit them until they are already
completely down all right
[Laughter]
ah i couldn't get it in time
not a big deal i would have liked the
fairy
it's not gonna lie to you fairy would
have been nice
but the parry is not necessary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god man it's so hard
[Music]
all right i gotta find a better way
a more consistent way of doing that part
[Laughter]
maybe
it would be crazy if it did i've never
noticed it but
you might be onto something man
two not going for that perry
they were trying to set your boy up with
that parry
[Music]
[Music]
look at this thing
[Music]
it's a weirdo man
weirdo
give me a parry card man give me a parry
car
or not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know why i didn't dodge that
[Music]
all right all right so i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna just be aggressive
when's the refrigerator part
starting to regress a little bit but
i'm good
[Laughter]
all right so let's try that
i don't know why that happened
oh my gosh
starting to lose it a little bit man
starting to lose my patience a little
bit
[Laughter]
oh you don't get a lot of time to parry
though
where do you get a giant shark from i
guess he is a magician
[Music]
giant shark shark's huge
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god why not jump
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
see if i get past the second round
all right well how close was that how
close was it
oh my god man he was about to go to the
second round
it's cool man it's cool
we making progress though that's all
that you could really ask for in these
type of games
gotta learn how to fight them learn
their patterns
uh
cycle might be on to something a little
bit by them changing up a little bit see
man i
feel like that was a little messed up
[Laughter]
here we go
see the problem is those homing missiles
are becoming a little bit of an
[Music]
issue wow
[Music]
[Music]
i didn't really like that too much well
i had a little too much
[Music]
oh my god man
[Music]
this boss is getting to me a little bit
it's that
it's that refrigerator man
[Music]
[Music]
give me a
pink card thank you
see i feel like sometimes they set you
up man
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like i'm doing a lot of damage to
him like to be honest with you
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well i was going to co-op with my
girlfriend but she didn't feel like
playing today so
[Music]
got to get through this man
[Music]
[Applause]
i keep getting attacked by like little
stuff just little stuff
[Music]
why am i teleporting behind me
just me messing up again man
that's all that is
oh my god relax aj relax
[Laughter]
[Music]
i need to just relax
let the stuff get to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
hmm
[Music]
gotta get this snowball when i can
[Music]
ice cubes
ice cubes
ice cubes
[Music]
man how much health does this thing
really realistically add i keep doing
serious damage to it man
[Music]
look at that
let one of them outer
oh i wanted that parry
got to be realistic with the matter
though
[Music]
all right so he's gonna
let's go ahead and get these ghosts
again i don't feel like
there we go
gotta parry
fairies are nice they're really nice
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so now the snowman
[Music]
okay what's he doing first
okay he's doing the sword thing
and he's teleporting
okay ice cube
big ice cubes
what's he doing next doing the sword
thing again
california probably gonna no he didn't
go above that time
[Music]
ice cube again
[Music]
we got these ice cubes going man
swords again
all right so what's going on here
what's going on here
what is this about
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
about halfway to his last form okay
but i'm getting it
i'm getting it
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
oh my god we're resetting where he said
someone was doing co-op
i'd like to do co-op i just got no one
to do co-op with and unfortunately
they still haven't implemented any type
of like live co-op in this i don't know
why
people determine just to make you do
co-op
uh
local like i get it like local co-op is
nice but
give us the option don't make us do
local i mean it's probably something
technical
probably this game wasn't going to be
that big at first until microsoft helped
publish it back in the day
[Music]
why
and he stopped trying to run that surely
all right so we got some more of these
[Music]
oh my god man these things
i'm aggression and we're guessing again
let's do this
we're going to switch because we don't
want them coming out too early this one
over here let's get it
some cars that we're just going to
teleport past
already again but it's fine
keep hitting them with this
i feel like he's doing those things like
a lot pretty consistently
[Music]
all right so let's go ahead and start
doing damage now remember we got a
pattern for him he's doing the sword so
we're going to dodge the sword
he's going back and forth
so he kind of messed me up there but
that's fine we good
let's just keep the damage up
doing the sword again
[Music]
we can't panic i'm panicking too much
panicking way too much
okay yeah i let him i let him trap me
there but that's fine
because that boss doesn't really give us
a good issue we gotta we gotta learn to
perfect the first boss again
we've lost
the first boss
so let's perfect the first boss
same with this little homie gun
i think there's someone over here
i'd love to get that perry but we can't
get that perry that perry's over there
it's like get hit by the giant whale
that he brings out of nowhere
let's get the first little good hits on
the snowman
let him come down
i gotta i can't i can't panic
let's do this the little cue balls like
it ain't that big of a deal
okay we took one damage it's fine though
one damage is fine
i panicked there and it took another
damage
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
this is rough man
[Music]
oh my god i would love to get a parry
but he does them way too late
all right ghosts
let's reset we don't want to do that we
want to go in there with three that last
thing
as good as we've been doing on that
second form there ain't no reason why we
don't go in there with three health
no reason whatsoever
[Music]
oh my god let's just die
i need to switch their fault
[Music]
all right
let's go back to the extra health
[Music]
because i feel like i don't need the um
i don't need this that much
[Music]
that extra health would be helpful
though going into those final games
[Music]
one over here
we got to stay consistent man
there we go love when we can get the
parries
[Music]
all right so what's he doing oh he's
doing the refrigerator first let's just
go ahead and dodge the refrigerator
no not not a big deal
[Music]
doing the sword that's fine
and of course i got hit oh yeah i can't
i have to dodge those now
we might go back to those
yeah let's let's let's go back to the
i didn't realize that i was using that
so much to make this a little bit easier
[Music]
i can dodge it i just
i just want consistency
man switched it up
um this um i don't have any of the uh
the other accounts on here
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i kind of need all that i think i could
do it without
i think i could do that last part
without the uh the jumping i just got to
be very careful
[Laughter]
yeah they got me they had me in the
between i should have looked left
[Music]
[Laughter]
there we go
let's do this guys
oh my god stop it stop messing up making
amateur stuff
[Music]
[Music]
it's fine let's just let's just go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get this damage in use the crack
shot and twin heart
i should probably unlock see
they do that stuff on purpose they get
you slipping
[Music]
[Music]
man i hate how i can't like maneuver
around some of those attacks
oh my god i feel like they're moving a
little more left and right
now go
a great slam and then
here goes
[Music]
just push up i guess
be a little bit more consistent with the
attacks
[Music]
oh my
god begin
there we go let's do this guys
[Music]
we got this guys
[Music]
look at the little snowman thing in the
back that's funny
i didn't jump all the way that's some
rock
just gotta
[Music]
double check when he does that
the one that goes up
[Music]
got one hell
well it's like three health deer in this
phase
[Music]
geez i i gotta stay below
[Music]
oh all right let's do this
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right we got this
[Music]
i've never seen him on the left it's
been a while since been on the left
yeah turn into the refrigerator man give
me a second to breathe
before you start doing any of that
unnecessary stuff
[Music]
come on
[Music]
all right we're so far so good guys so
far so good
[Music]
he's got to be close to being took down
man
of course i get hit at the very end
[Music]
all right so we we got a good amount of
health to fight this dude here
[Music]
oh my god
a little bit a little bit to halfway a
little bit to halfway
[Music]
it's best to go around i've noticed
don't try to stay in one location you're
gonna get you're gonna get screwed up
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
all right there we go do do something
different give me a little bit more time
man
something different
[Music]
there's one over here
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's get some easy damage
now remember we don't have that smoke
thing anymore so
we have to take that into consideration
now we had to dodge him
but i think the smoke thing was the
right move
[Music]
because i feel like we're doing better
now
[Music]
still in the little refrigerator thing a
lot noticed
all right here we go
[Music]
this lightning thing
i hope i'm hitting them
that would suck if i'm not hitting them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
man it's doing so good
[Music]
now go
[Laughter]
yeah i shouldn't went for that perry
there's too much going on
sometimes i get greedy with the parry if
i see it i want it
yeah i messed up man
this is the second boss
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god man why'd i jump
they get you used to
to dodging a certain way
and then oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll read the the chat after this
attempt
hopefully if it's not an attempt
hopefully we finish it
but if i don't chat i'll read it then
[Music]
so remember we got to jump over
anything involving
thing came straight at me
[Music]
oh my god man
they trick you
[Music]
got two two attacks
you know i'm a
i'ma stick to this to see if i can just
dodge the stuff
[Music]
all right
let's hit him
they do the little light things
afterwards
all right we're doing good this probably
my couple more attempts guys i'm
probably done
got stuff i gotta do
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's kind of crazy how this game
oh my
sometimes i feel like it doesn't it
doesn't actually
gravitate towards the way it's supposed
to
[Laughter]
i don't know just depend on what happens
man
[Music]
i got stuff i have to do today
[Music]
okay
so we got the refrigerator got the
little ice cubes you know they're not
too hard to dodge
oh my god i didn't just get hit oh my
[Music]
[Music]
so we got two again
yeah i think that's it for the day man
guys definitely follow me on twitter
find out if i uh
stream anything more
tomorrow i got a lot of stuff i need to
get done but i'll talk to you guys later
gave you guys about two hours two hours
appreciate it though
i enjoyed it so so far it's fun